[Music]
china now badly needs a new growth
engine china is far more reliant on real
estate as a driver of economic growth
than anywhere else in the world
president xi considers housing policy as
the central part of its common
prosperity drive a lot of people look at
green technology as a potential savior
[Music]
the meltdown at evergrand the world's
most indebted real estate company has
been unfolding in a dramatic way and it
could signal a huge shift in the way the
chinese economy works it's clear that
the economic model that drove china's
world-beating growth over the last two
decades or more is running out of road
what follows now is uncertain but it
could entail significantly lower
economic growth for the world's second
largest economy this is important for
the whole world because china has been
the major contributor to global growth
for the past few decades in the five
years to 2018 china accounted for up to
one third of global growth
the problem however is that
real estate has been driving china's
growth for too much and for too long
and that cannot continue forever
china now badly needs a new growth
engine
this footage shows 15 apartment
buildings being torn down in the
southwestern city of queen ming
recently as these buildings have stayed
idle for the past few years
such things are by no means uncommon in
china as the country is now home to one
of the world's largest number of
unoccupied apartments
during my recent trip to the eastern
city of jinan i found the city is
scattered with empty apartments and
empty buildings
many home buyers were forced to move
into these half built apartments
as local developers were too cash
strapped to finish these complexes
this chart shows the extent of the
problem compared to other countries
china is far more reliant on real estate
as a driver of economic growth than
anywhere else in the world spain is the
only place that came close in 2008 and
that bubble burst in spectacular fashion
so soon
we've had this situation of an overbuilt
chinese property market for a long time
why are people getting so worried about
it now
the reason people are getting so worried
this time is because
president xi jinping is in power in
china this time and he famously said
that housing is for living not for
speculating
and president xi considers housing
policy as the central part of its common
prosperity drive
housing affordability in china right now
is among the worst in the whole world
as of the end of last year it would take
an average of 25 years of household
income in a southern hub of shenzhen to
purchase an apartment
in contrast the figure is about 13 in
london and eight in new york
apparently president xi couldn't
tolerate this and he wants things to
change
and the solution is the so-called three
red lines which is three
financial ratios mostly debt ratios that
china's real estate developers must
follow in order to gain access to credit
the policy which was launched last
august has had a huge impact on the
industry as many developers led by
evergrant
are in deep financial trouble for
failing to follow these requirements
so james if china's real estate driven
growth model is running out of steam
what would be next growth engine for
china
so the question of what type of growth
engine can emerge in china to take up
the slack from the sputtering real
estate sector is really the 64 million
dollar question going forward um and i
think a lot of people look at green
technology as a potential savior
china's record in this area is truly
remarkable uh china's installed more
solar power more wind power than any
other country in the world and in the
case of wind power the amount of wind
farm capacity that was added last year
was greater than the rest of the world
put together also in electric vehicles
it's quite stunning what chinese
companies are doing
so far over 40 percent of all the
electric vehicles sold in the world have
been sold in china you can really tell
the chinese government is behind this
one of the biggest figures to emerge
from china over the last month was an
estimate by zhang xiaohui
dean of the school of finance at ching
hua university who said that china would
need between now and 2060
about
46.6 trillion u.s dollars to put behind
its carbon neutrality
drive
it just to put that number into
perspective that means that every year
between now and 2060 china will be
investing 1.2 trillion u.s dollars
that is equivalent to the size of the
entire indonesian economy so there's no
question that china's really serious
about this it's just too early to say i
think
whether or not this green technology
area will be big enough and attract
enough investment to really compensate
for the flagging real estate sector
despite the huge potential for green
revolution china still relies heavily on
fossil fuels to power its economic
growth
coal-fired power plants currently
account for more than two-thirds of
china's energy consumption
unfortunately the authority has largely
underestimated the situation
in the first eight months of this year
china's coal output grew only four
percent thanks to the closure of
hundreds of coal mines across the
country at the same time the countries
of energy consumption picked up by 15
percent
owing largely to the post-pandemic
global economic recovery that boosted
china's exports by more than 35 percent
in the same period
the so this combined suggests that china
is still having a long way to go in
making a transition from
an economy that's driven by traditional
economy by real estate to one that's
powered more by renewable energy and
other more sustainable models